one of the things you said that stuck
with me is that we teach our kids what
to do in case of a fire
but they're much more likely to to
experience some kind of abuse than they
are to have a fire in the house
and so we should be trying to educate
them
uh about what to do with their bodies i
thought that was very compelling because
one in four
girls and one in six boys is staggering
again this is because
it's such a difficult subject to talk
about
it's the reason why i wanted to create a
resource that was going to be useful
um and enable more conversation we teach
kids
how to cross the street safely you know
how to
make sure um they are
safe in the event of a fire but
statistically
they're much more likely to be sexually
abused than to be in a house fire
so this is a safety book
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks we
have the greatest guest we've ever had
evelyn yang joins yang speaks wife of
andrew yang talks about her new book
on sexual assault awareness for kids
and also talks about what it's like to
be married to andrew yang you're not
going to want to miss this
they are an amazing couple and two
amazing human beings that complement
each other well you're gonna love it
evelyn yang
joins yang speaks right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks the greatest guest of all time
the most important the love of my life
evelyn yang welcome to the podcast
evelyn
thanks for coming hello mr yang
hello mrs yang we are a couple of rooms
away from each other
and yet i you gonna feel so official
because you have your own background i'm
very proud of this background i made
this background for
damien zoom school you know he had the
chicest background of all his classmates
thanks to you
and people should know that evelyn has
also been upgrading my zoom backgrounds
uh for uh four months so anything good
that's happened
it was probably evelyn as it's true in
most of my life uh
i feel like people who listen to this
podcast know you
already when folks met you it was when
you first started
campaigning for um was
campaigning with me as i was running for
president i was going to say campaigning
for president
uh and i i remember distinctly where you
were so surprised that people were so
happy to see you when we were out and
about i was like oh yeah they've been
they've been excited to see you for
quite some time
oh yeah it was a it was kind of a shock
actually
you know it was um mostly
at home minding the kids while you were
on the trail for
a good at least half of it i think and
then the first time i came out with you
on the trail it was close to my birthday
and i think i had
i don't know how large that crowd was
like maybe a thousand people
singing happy birthday to me that was
just such a trip
and seeing all the energy and how much
love there was for you i was like wow
andrew was telling this
he wasn't he wasn't overstating this
well there's a lot of love for you baby
and i have no idea how i the campaign
without you after you showed up because
when you started campaigning it was so
much better like world's better
um i feel like everyone in the team felt
that too you know
it was a special time
um and then when we got the kids on the
trail too it was also
awesome uh when that we got them on the
bus and whatnot they still have a very
very
special place in their hearts for iowa i
think they see it as a winter wonderland
totally they're the only kids here i
think that have been to iowa so many
times
a lot of people ask you this and i
suppose i'll ask you
you as well how did you feel about my
decision
when i came to you saying hey how about
my running for president
back in the day i guess you and i
started having that conversation
uh in like 2017 after
trump won so many people ask us that
question and i think
most people think or they regard it as
something that happened overnight
and the truth is it was a progression
right
um and we were having these
conversations around
what was happening to our country like
how did donald trump
get elected and i think that question
literally kept you up at night
like you were losing sleep and you were
wrestling with it
and trying to make sense of it and in
the way that you do
you know you started digging into the
numbers and the research
and then you discovered you know um
automation and how donald trump won the
election
yeah it did take place over months it's
true i remember vividly seeing
the facts and figures around the
automation of manufacturing jobs in the
midwest that mapped
almost district by district to the the
voters that trump needed to win and did
win
and i thought wow someone needs to
explain this to people
and then actually propose real solutions
uh and do you remember the first time i
brought universal basic income home to
you
because i actually i'm not sure when i
did bring that home to you i think you
started
by reading a book so did you meet andy
stern first or did you read his book
first
i definitely read his book first right
so it seemed like you read his book
first and then as you were reading his
book
you i think we had some conversations as
you were
reading his book and um and you were
really excited about it and then you
were really excited when you met him
and i think that's actually the first
time
you might have come back and said i need
to
popularize this idea and the way to do
that
is to run for president yeah so the book
that that
evelyn's talking about is
raising the floor by andy stern he wrote
this book in 2015
and it was so impactful and powerful for
me because he's one of the greatest
labor leaders of our time
and so when technologists like eric
brynjolfsson
or martin ford say hey technology is
going to eat the jobs
and you're looking at it saying like
okay you would think that because you're
a technologist and you're going to see
things from the
point of view but then when one of the
great labor leaders of the
country says technology's going to eat
the jobs you're like wait a minute
you would not have a vested interest in
this point of view at all quite the
opposite
so if you come to this conclusion people
really want to listen
uh and it makes sense that when i read
his book and i was
talking to you excitedly about it evelyn
you were like oh universal basic income
and one of the reasons why we both
became
so excited about the presidential run
was we came together on universal basic
income
and felt like okay the world really
needs this totally and what it would
mean
in terms of eradicating poverty um what
it would mean to
caregivers around the country it made so
much sense to me
that i thought okay if you go out and
promote this idea
somebody else will pick it up oh yeah
that's what you said
i was like there's no way that this idea
won't become
the new medicare for all and then
you can pass on that torch and come home
and be normal again
yes and when i got out there i remember
coming back to you and saying
i'm not sure anyone else is going to
pick this up in the way that
that you're imagining though i did get
a number of candidates to sign on to it
but they weren't the major candidates
i got marianne williamson and tulsi
and others uh to
commit to some version of universal
basic income i was after
i didn't think i was ever gonna get joe
but i i was after bernie really
uh in in a big way and it was always
mystifying as you know baby that i was
like
but i mean look at it it just basically
took a like a year longer than you
thought yeah unfortunately due to the
circumstances but now we're seeing cash
relief in various versions
the child poverty tax credit that is
getting started this summer
i don't think people are talking about
it enough it's hundreds of dollars a
month for
millions of families i mean it's
literally going to
reduce poverty for almost half the
families that are in poverty right now
that have kids
it's really astonishing and the fact
that you and i might have had something
to do with that
uh is is like the greatest thing ever
it's the greatest and it's just the
beginning
right how many u.s cities now are
piloting ubi
dozens happily and i don't think people
know this but when i tell people
they're very surprised to hear that when
you first started running for president
you didn't even have um your name and it
was i think you called it like
ubi 2020 that's what it was on your on
the website that was on
that was what was on your business card
like your name wasn't
even in there it wasn't yang 2020 it was
ubi 2020. and then people started
being like who's behind this who
and that's when you change your name
yeah also ubi didn't really have the
kind of currency or impact that you kind
of hoped it's like you be what like you
know
uti it was not so we went with yang
which and then the rest is history
[Music]
this episode yang speaks is brought to
you by all form guys
i'm sitting on my all form couch right
now
i don't always record ads sitting on the
couch but i thought it'd be fun for this
ad
so we've talked about helix mattresses
because they're awesome matches but the
same
company is making amazing couches using
the awesome cushy quality they have in
their mattresses on their couch and it's
so
easy all form is awesome you can
customize your couch
or sofa using premium materials guys i
literally
got i had a cut on my leg and i put
basta tracing on it and i got it on the
couch
and i just put a little water on this
little dish soap on it and it came right
off
as if it's gone these couches don't
stain they're freaking
awesome you can assemble them yourself
the color looks great i get compliments
on it
all the time i've slept on it i've sat
on it i've watched tv on it
it looks great is cool it's well priced
this thing is freaking awesome plus they
deliver it to you you can assemble it
yourself
it's freaking fantastic they offer a
forever warranty
literally forever so to find your
perfect sofa
check out allform.com yang again
all form is offering 20 off all orders
for our listeners
again at allform.com slash yangmith
allform.com
yang
[Applause]
you shared your story of being
sexually assaulted uh by your doctor
which obviously you and i
you know shared years earlier with the
world
late in the campaign it was late 2020
uh and that was such like a a
massive decision on your part i think
that's when really most people
got to know you uh and i was obviously a
part
of some of that process but can you talk
people through
what that process was like for you and
how you actually arrived at
the decision to stand in front of the
world or
or share your experiences with so many
people
i never imagined having um the kind of
platform that
we did and this had been a burden
on me just a secret that i had been
carrying
for many years ever since i was pregnant
with christopher
and um you know being on the trail was a
very very empowering
experience on many levels first
there were so many women
actually who were sharing their stories
of harassment
of assault with me in particular
and i remember thinking wow you guys are
so brave
um and i have my own story to share
um but i was too scared you know to do
it
but i felt empowered by them
empowered by the love and support
um that came to us just from you know
the campaign and i also felt this
incredible obligation um to use the
platform that i had at that moment
um and try to support other other women
and other survivors
so i do feel like it was
the moment that um enabled
you know my coming forward it was rough
though
i i remember wrestling with it for
a long time and i think you know the
week leading up to
my cnn interview i probably lost 10
pounds
um but i'm so glad i did that and i
absolutely did not anticipate
um so many other women
coming forward about the same doctor
right like dozens and dozens of women i
think over
he was practicing for over 20 years
thinking about
how many women he abused during the
course of his career is just chilling
and to know that i
helped that many other women
um come forward about something where
like me they probably thought they were
completely alone maybe it was something
that they did
um yeah that means i mean that that's
everything
i do remember the days leading up to
your interview and
i just wanted to be supportive i i just
wanted to say whatever you want to do
um though i
too saw the love and support you were
getting on the trail even before you
came out
with the story about what happened with
dr haddon
and you were getting all these messages
about different issues that women were
facing
but after your interview it was
10 or 20 times that where everywhere we
went
women would just come to you sometimes
in tears
talking about their own experiences it
was overwhelming
the support that you got but also the
level of pain and struggle that so many
women
faced i mean i i was a witness to
people coming to you so many times and
uh i was so proud of you baby
uh i mean i i was somewhat
overwhelmed too by the level of
attention that your story received
rightfully so but i felt like everyone
saw that interview i got text messages
from
dozens of our friends and and this
actually hit me and i'm sure you did too
where dozens of of our friends texted me
and said i'm so sorry i never knew and
then
uh it dawned on me it was like oh yeah
like now our friends would know
uh that that this had happened and i
thought well like i've known and
like i struggled with it for years with
like the anger and pain
and guilt on my part um
but then after you shared it uh so many
other people knew and it touched so many
people so for
so profoundly that i feel like you
couldn't help but feel
like it was a tremendous thing to do
because i feel like you set a lot of
people free
i feel like you liberated a lot of women
well i certainly
did so for um other survivors of this
doctor
um that i know and and i was kind of
smiling when you
when you said um you know people coming
up to us because i remember very
distinctly that
after my interview you know we would do
events
and you know you would have your own
selfie line and then i would have my own
and it was beautiful but also incredibly
um telling of how just many of us are
walking around
with this trauma and um
a lot of tears and a lot of support for
one another
it was that was something that i was not
anticipating
at all i didn't know that coming
for or sharing a story myself would mean
that other people would
want to share with me to that level and
um and i actually feel so grateful for
the experience because it's
it's even more um i think healing for me
to channel some of that trauma
and and be able to help other people
deal with theirs
catharsis i think is the word like it's
cathartic yes
absolutely and i think that's what we
need more of right and it's the reason
why we encourage survivors
to share their stories because it's a
burden off them
and it also helps other people because
it just opens the door
to uh more people sharing you know i
work with
um you know rain they're the largest
anti-sexual assault
um network in the uh in the country
and they tell me so they run a 24 7
hotline uh where you can
talk to someone train confidentially um
any time of day and they say that after
me too every all of the work that we've
been doing over these past years
it's not that the calls decline the
calls just
increase because the more people come
forward
the more other people want to come
forward you referenced that
a number of women came forward about dr
haddon
i know it was dozens of women it was
over 40 and
that had a real impact on his treatment
and
that case the the
federal government ended up
investigating him
as a result of all of these women coming
forward
that that must have been incredibly
gratifying for you
it was it was the first time i felt like
what he did was actually taken seriously
and so i'm very very grateful
that he was actually arrested and he's
being investigated
um for abusing minors under his care
awful yeah yeah and
um and i think they called him at the
press conference a predator in a white
coat
and i had not heard him up until that
time
ever described that way and
it illustrated to me just
how they finally understood
um his mo right
that this was calculated you know he
would prey on
pregnant women like me
[Music]
who um in my first pregnancy
was very unaware of how
these visits were supposed to go and
then also
young women for their first visits
now he's being described as maybe one of
the most prolific
predators in the state and he was very
very close to getting away with it
and he didn't thanks to you and so many
other women who came forward
i despise this man and his existence
uh and i know i speak for so many people
when
uh i say thank you evelyn uh for helping
get him on the way to being behind bars
which is where he belongs
he's hurt and traumatized so many people
and abuse their trust
in a really violative manner
i mean you go to a doctor and you expect
to be treated and
taken care of and he
attacked and abused people
a few decades ago private citizens used
to be just that
private and what's changed the internet
everything you've ever browned searched
watched
tweeted you name it it's all being
crawled through on the back end through
your data
it's going through third parties becomes
public record
permanently it's your record so to keep
our data private
andrew and i when we go online we use
expressvpn
there are hundreds of data brokers out
there and their sole businesses to buy
and sell your data and expressvpn
prevents them
from doing that our connection gets
rerouted through an encrypted server
and our ip address our mass so every
time i turn on expressvpn i just press a
little button
it gives me a random ip address shared
by other expressvpn
customers that is used to keep us all
private and safe it makes it more
difficult for third parties to identify
me
and harvest my data or harvest andrew's
data
it's awesome so here's the deal if you
are like us and believe that your data
should be your business
not other people's business secure
yourself with the number one rated vpn
on the market visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months for free
that's expressvpn.com
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
yang go to expressvpn.com yang to learn
more
right now
[Applause]
so now to something a little bit more uh
current and
and positive uh how did this book come
about
uh i know that that you were at least
thinking about it but then
the i think someone reached out to you i
had this book in me
pretty much as soon as i started talking
about
what happened with me with the doctor it
was because i
was looking for a way to explain what
happened to me
to our kids and also um
protect them from something that i knew
was
quite prevalent i did not realize the
extent of it you know it's
one in four girls and one in six boys
will be sexually abused before age 18.
that's a lot
that that's astoundingly high yes there
are over 40 million americans
right now um who
have experienced sexual abuse and it's
not something we talk about
right it's so taboo it's so
uncomfortable from what i was seeing
there wasn't a like a consumer resource
for for this like a a book for
parents or educators or families
um you know i'm i'm not a doctor
or clinician and this book is not a
clinical book
um usually the subject matter
usually comes across in a more clinical
way which i had a hard time with
this book is written in the point of
view of
a survivor me and it's the book that i
wanted to read to our kids
the difficulty was in illustrating this
book
and i if you remember we you know
i don't know if you remember we we
talked about like what are we gonna use
to illustrate this like are we gonna use
like
animals like what kind of animals
bunnies bears
and i think it was very um
lucky that i discovered a kid's book
about
and their experts at handling
heavy topics like sexual abuse
and uh racism and
addiction big topics but distilling it
down to
a um conversation starter almost
for kids um and their and their
grown-ups
and it's just to get just plant the
seeds
you know no matter how heavy the subject
i
feel like all of their books are
actually very positive and affirming
and accessible so we're just planting
those seeds of awareness
and compassion and empathy
um it's really what we need you know i
really believe that we have to start
young with these subjects
it's too late when they're
you know conditioned by their peers by
the media all these things that get in
the way where it's hard to break through
we we have to start very young so that
um they understand their impact on
others
one of the things you said that stuck
with me is that we teach our kids what
to do in case of a fire
but they're much more likely to to
experience some kind of abuse than they
are to have a fire in the house
and so we should be trying to educate
them
about what to do with their bodies i
thought that was very compelling because
one in four
girls and one in six boys is staggering
yeah
um again this is because it's such a
difficult
subject to talk about it's the reason
why
i wanted to create a resource that was
going to be useful
um and enable more conversation we teach
kids
how to cross the street safely you know
how to
make sure um they are
safe in the event of a fire but
statistically
they're much more likely to be sexually
abused than to be in a house fire
um so this is a safety book you know
first and foremost
it teaches kids the signs of sexual
abuse
and the importance of reporting it
should it happen
and that's everything you know just
telling kids over and over again
that um the most important thing you can
possibly do
is to tell someone don't be afraid to
tell anyone
i i love this book um i was again i mean
they do it so intelligently and
tastefully i mean it's a lot of word art
so back to the point about how
we illustrate this book what's awesome
about the series
is that it's all word art so it's just
words but it's still
really emotive and um
right yes your private parts are private
and um
anyway you get the point it's just it's
just words
and the words speak for themselves yeah
it's really wonderful and you're
donating all proceeds
from the book to reign and we're trying
to get copies into
primary schools around the country is
that right
right so i am donating all royalties to
rain
and um you know i have a goal of getting
this
into you know the hands of um
guidance counselors and therapists um
and educators i don't know if i told you
this but i was having a conversation
with um
the guidance counselor at damien school
back when i was still working on it
we were talking talking talking and then
he said what's the title of the book
again
and i said oh it's a kid's book about
sexual abuse and he said
a kid's book about i love a kid's book
about and
uh he's like i have all of their books
um and i use them with my kids and
they're so effective
and we we can get through such tough
topics
um but the kids feel really good about
it and they take away so much and i
was like this is amazing i'm so so
grateful that you know i found a series
for this book to live in
it's such a good series i recommend all
of their titles
um it's on oprah's favorite list for a
reason
i'm just really proud to be able to have
this subject now part of that
you know that broader conversation of
you know educating our kids early
um teaching them these important issues
that
we don't usually approach with them
until
later and i think that's a mistake well
you're helping to change it
and i'm so thrilled that that guidance
counselor
loves these books as much as you and i
do not
you've been talking to organizations
and activists about ways that you can
help
protect kids from abuse
even in addition to this book uh and
your advocacy of rain which is a
tremendous organization
um i think you you just had a
conversation with uh the biden
foundation to that effect
yeah i actually participated in a
training with them yesterday
they uh their organization
helps prevent child abuse in general all
kinds of child abuse
and it's wonderful um training
what i learned so much one of the things
that's really disturbing
is the the new predator the new sexual
predator
it's not the same predator that you
might imagine
you know uh riding around
in like a minivan looking for kids and
playgrounds to pick up
the new frontier is online gaming
no yes and if you can imagine
um for them it's like a paradise because
these are
fish in a barrel to them right these
young kids
um over i want us 39
of online gamers are over 35 years old
so they're not all kids and they're
there
and they're picking their prey they're
literally
in kids bedrooms because they're gaming
together and there's so these
multiplayer online games
um and you know they're on teams
together
and parents are not aware one of the
most important things to do
is to establish safety guidelines
early on and to revisit those guidelines
regularly
sorry gamers i know most of you are
awesome and
like just there for the the enjoyment of
the game
um so you if you have an older guy
who um is a predator then is their goal
then to try and find some
young boy typically because i feel like
boys play these games much more than
girls
and then get together with them in
person is that like a progression
so 46 of gamers right now are girls um
so the girls are definitely catching up
to the boys but yeah
they for them it's a they're very
patient that's one thing that i've
learned about
sexual predators they're very patient
um you know they start
very benignly they will add um
you know maybe give you gifts if you you
know how
obsessed our kids now are with roblox
and robux
um they might give you a gift and earn
your trust
that way and then help you you know
acquire things and items that
um are desirable to you and then um
you know try to move the relationship um
from online offline but even in an
online relationship you know there's
something um that i learned
yesterday it's called sextortion and
it's
it is what you imagine it to be which is
you know they extort you for
photos it could start out innocent just
like
take photos of either
your home or your outfit
and then it just gets progressively
worse and it's really really important
for
grown-ups and parents to be vigilant
wow it's very dark when you say it out
loud it makes perfect sense
um but it's not the kind of thing that
most parents think about
it's not and i would say i'm saying it's
it's new it's new for us
it's new for most parents um but again
what's the same is that any kind of
abuse
there's stigma there's shame there's
guilt
and these are the things that i cover in
my book these are the things that don't
change
and again the single most important
thing
that kids can ever do in the situation
is
to tell someone that's how the abuse
stops
and that's how we can prevent abuse from
happening
to other kids because we also know that
predators
have multiple victims the reporting
levels
are just terrible they're dismal they're
16 of sex tortion cases are actually
reported to the police
i i'm so glad that we're sharing this
with people because a lot of people
particularly parents hearing this will
be like wow i hadn't thought about this
and you know your kids online
interacting with people
you assume it's benign you assume
they're having fun but uh there's some
darkness uh lurking uh behind the fun
sometimes oh baby i am so proud of you i
love you so much
and seeing you grow over this last
number
of months into this amazing advocate for
women for children for
families with special needs it's been
one of the joys of my life
i mean certainly you and i both know
that like neither of us really
could have foreseen so many steps in
this journey
that we've been sharing um but but
seeing you greeted on the trail with so
much love and
warmth and enthusiasm and then seeing
the impact you've had
on so many women through sharing your
story and then now having you
fight for families not just our family i
mean anytime someone thanks me
when i'm out in the world i say thank
you
like thank my wife uh for making any of
it possible
but i'm just so proud of you and uh
i'm um so grateful to to you every
single day and i think there are a lot
of other people
listening to this are watching this that
um that share
my gratitude thank you
um i'm very grateful too you know
that i get spiritual sometimes and i
think about how we never imagined
neither of us that we would be in a
place to be able to impact
people's lives in such a way and
you know when you started running for
president
i i was very much
content in my role as
supporting you um in your mission to you
know change the way
people um thought about the economy
and the future and also to eradicate
poverty i mean that was
enough that's plenty for me but i i
really never
imagined that i would be in a position
to use my own personal experiences um
to help people in almost a completely
different way
the things that we experience happen for
a reason
and wherever we are in a in any given
moment we can only do
the best we can with it um
and just trust that it's you know for
good
well it certainly is for good in in your
case and i try and make it for good in
my case
um thank you for everything you do for
our family and for families everywhere
evelyn
i love you and i'm sure a lot of more
people uh you know love you
out there listening to this and watching
this as well thank you for coming on
you're the best guest ever
i'm not just saying that because you're
my wife and the love of my life
most downloaded episode ever
i love you anytime you want to come on
baby we could just make this the
the andrew and evelyn yang speaks
podcasted like that this is just like
every week it'll be like what are andrew
and evelyn talking about this week
wow that actually i mean heck i'd enjoy
[Laughter]
[Music]
that
you